what's driving you crazy how about a
brief appearance of the ghost
of project neon this weekend you know
back during the remake of i-15 through
the spaghetti bowl
there were a lot of closures of the ramp
from 95 south to the south 15.
well the nevada department of
transportation is scheduling an
eight-hour closure of not just that ramp
but others in the area as well
so it's gonna be sunday from six in the
morning scheduled to last until two that
afternoon
crews will be replacing a damaged crash
barrier
but three other ramps are affected that
includes the south 95
collector road that starts at decatur
although the exits to decatur and valley
will stay open
also the ramp to get onto the south 95
from valley view that's going to be
closed
the south 95 off ramps to both rancho
and mlk
will also be closed now the 95 itself
will stay open and that includes the hov
flyover
from the south 95 to the south 15. we
have this story up on our website
because that's a lot of information to
try to grab hold of
but you just click traffic and then
click driving you crazy buckle up drive
carefully and please put down that phone
if there's something driving you crazy
email me traffic eight
at eightnewsnow.com